bitcoin up big today couple of percent
which means that we're starting to get
thousands of dollars in single 24-hour
movements compared to other assets
bitcoin is dominating up 3 000 up even
more now almost at 67 000 that's how
fast this is moving we screenshotted
this about an hour ago to put it in here
if we then go and we start to look at
the actual underlying comparison of the
roi of bitcoin what you find is that
bitcoin is up 433
over the last 12 months gold is down 7
they have printed trillions and
trillions of dollars they've manipulated
interest rates lower and the entire
financial world has dropped gold and
chosen bitcoin to be the inflation hedge
asset and that's where you see that 433
increase over the last 12 months if you
go and you look five years ago now if
you had bought bitcoin five years ago
and held it to today you're up over 10
000
absolutely bonkers numbers that's a 10x
higher percentage
return than the s p 500 if we then go
and we look at the bitcoin price closing
history well if we're at an all-time
high that means anyone who has ever
bought bitcoin and held it till today is
up in terms of purchasing power they
have successfully protected and
appreciated their purchasing power never
a single day above the price that we
currently sit at right now that is the
beauty of an all-time high of an asset
and so if we go ahead and we look at the
actual market cap of bitcoin and some of
the other fundamental metrics we can see
bitcoin now up over 1.25 trillion
dollars with the recent price movement
bitcoin settlement over the last 24
hours over 20 billion dollars settled on
chain and the miners got paid 60 million
dollars in the last 24 hours to secure
the bitcoin blockchain 60 million
dollars to people all around the world
to plug in machines and secure the
strongest most decentralized computing
network in the world that is the beauty
of an economic incentive so absolutely
crazy watching this all play out now if
the price is going to hit an all-time
high lots and lots of other metrics also
hitting all-time highs we have the
market cap obviously hitting an all-time
high of 1.25 trillion we also have the
bitcoin lightning network capacity
hitting an all-time high we look at this
we've got 3113
bitcoin now you can see it right there
overlaid on top of price
3113 bitcoin and lightning network
capacity all-time high and then of
course if the price continues to move
upwards we have 22 363
bitcoin realized price the realized
price continues to hit all-time highs
just as much as the actual spot price
does as well and so whether
you hold bitcoin or not it is undeniable
now that buying it and holding it till
today has been a good decision what we
are watching is an asset that remember
85 of the circulating supply has not
moved in the last 90 days demand is
increasing we just had the etf launch
yesterday on top of that interactive
brokers opening up rias and there is now
billions of dollars starting to flow
into the market but once we break an
all-time high that all-time high of 64
about 850
there is nothing above that price point
literally there is almost no supply
above the previous all-time high and so
we enter something called price
discovery and the question is how far
and how fast do we go up do we go up to
67 000 where we're basically at right
now do we go to 70 75 80 85 90 95 100
there is going to be price discovery in
the past when we've broken previous
all-time highs there's been material
appreciation of price we continued to
talk about this all summer long all of
q3 and into the beginning of q4 you
can't say that you weren't warned if you
watched this show when we watched the
price break joe and john what was your
reaction there's a lot of yelling and
screaming and a lot of yup that was
exactly what we expected to happen at
some point well i'm pumped obviously i
mean look like we all own bitcoin we're
very clear about that uh so so from a
personal standpoint yeah it's great but
also it also means that every single
person that has ever purchased bitcoin
and held until today is now in the
profit right so there's people that in
the last run-up and when i went to 60 65
000 last time maybe they learned about
it at that time period maybe that was
the uh you know the span of time where
they got a lot of their money into the
market put a considerable amount of
their savings or whatever right so it's
good to know that every single person
that bought the asset and has held onto
it today with strong conviction is up in
profit and then to your point i think
like this is really just the beginning
right like we we waited for this and
it's a cool uh moment to see it break
the all-time high again and it's uh
certainly rewarding uh from that aspect
but from the thought process of look
countries are buying bitcoin uh
corporations are putting billions of
dollars of bitcoin on their balance
sheet and have said publicly they're not
going to sell uh etfs are being approved
institutions are uh buying lots of
bitcoin and coming into the asset class
and then when you talk about it from the
supply side 85 of it right has not moved
in 90 days so we're gonna see kind of
how that trends over the next month or
two uh but i would be surprised yeah if
we're not considerably higher 80 90 100
000
rather soon i would i would john what do
you think i'm pumped i'm looking forward
to 100k and a lot higher i mean this is
it's going to be another milestone i
think right so every time we've broken
the all-time high we've gone around what
8.8 x um up over the next like 12 months
or so so i'm excited to see what is
about to happen the stock to flow model
for plan b still on track that means
we're gonna have to stay above what i
think 150 000 for a very long time so i
think this is just another milestone i'm
obviously very excited but uh there's
there's more to come in my mind